this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the ultimate all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business you can
check out squarespace through the link
in the description below more about them
in a bit
it was the era of great east asian
authoritarians up in china and mao
zedong clung to power in south korea
park chung he
mixing economic progress with an iron
fist in the philippines in indonesia
corrupt kleptocrats ferdinand marcos and
sahato were plundering the nation's
treasuries to say nothing of the mad
house in north korea it was a time of
strongmen are powerful rulers who
dominated their nations but not all of
them would be awful on a tiny island at
the south of the malay peninsula one man
would forge a different kind of regime a
hybrid that would mix authoritarianism
with democracy oppressive laws with
staggering wealth free market capitalism
with state control known as lee kuan yew
he would create modern singapore coming
to power at the end of the colonial era
lee inherited a singapore still ruined
by war and riven with poverty and ethnic
divisions yet he somehow managed to
transform it into one of the richest
safest nations on earth controversial in
his methods brilliant in his results
this is the story of singapore's father
[Laughter]
given that he's now famous for
championing singaporean independence it
can be a surprise to discover just how
much lee kuan yew benefited from british
rule when he was born on september 16
1923 it wasn't into a world of poverty
and depression but into a family
embedded among the colonial elite as a
fourth generation straight chinese the
lays were part of an ethnic group who'd
come to control the british colony
decades before mixing their culture with
that of both the local malay and the
ruling british for lee that meant
growing up in a mostly english-speaking
environment until he was an adult nearly
everyone he knew called him harry lee it
also meant growing up in relative
comfort with his solidly middle-class
parents lee was able to attend the
raffles institution an elite school
named after the port city's british
founder but while he was certainly
pampered young harry lee wasn't just
coasting through life although
undoubtedly part of the elite the boy's
family came from the lower rungs of the
privileged ladder less the one percent
and more the struggling to get into the
one percent this gave him a drive many
of his peers lack to drive to prove his
worth when lee graduated in 1939 it
wasn't just at the head of his class but
ahead of any other student in the whole
colony of british malaya it was a
vintage piece of lee kuan yew a
combination of searing intelligence
extreme determination but also a desire
to show off to prove he was better than
anyone else and it worked that far lee
planned to go to study at a prestigious
university in england just the first
step on a short staircase that would
take him to the top of the colonial
administration but you know what they
say about the best laid plans of mice
and men while the arrival of world war
ii was about to do to lee's plans what a
sadistic cat does to a helpless mouse
the eruption of conflict in europe
forced the ambitious young man to stay
put in singapore trading england's green
and pleasant land for a scholarship at
raffles college it wasn't all a bust it
was while studying that lee met his
future wife lawsuit and kwa gyoku on the
other hand it also meant that he was
still in singapore in early 1942 when
the japanese imperial army came rolling
in the battle of singapore began on
february the 8th after the fall of
mainland british malay by now the
colonial authorities had destroyed the
bridges to the islands and concentrated
their forces of tens of thousands of
troops with the added advantage of a
defensive ring of heavy guns they
theoretically could have kept the
japanese at bay in the end though they
barely managed to hold them off for a
week despite an order from churchill to
keep fighting singapore's governor
surrendered on february the 15th at
which point the imperial army did what
it did best and launched a campaign of
mass murder as a straight chinese the
japanese occupation was an odd time for
lee on the one hand the japanese were
actively hunting down and killing
chinese people on the island one time
lee was nearly caught by a death squad
another he was interrogated and
humiliated on the other hand he was also
part of the elite the japanese still
needed to run their new territory once
the chaos of the invasion was over
family connections managed to get him a
job at the imperial news agency dumay
where he quickly learned japanese what
he was really doing there remains
uncertain in the closing days of the war
lee was suddenly forced to go into
hiding it's been speculated that he was
passing information onto british
intelligence and may have been
discovered whatever the truth lee
managed to stay underground until the
danger had passed on the 12th of
september 1945 british forces liberated
singapore yet lee didn't exactly welcome
them back with open arms the easy
surrender of singapore had left many on
the island with a bitter taste in their
mouths from seeing himself as part of
the colonial elite he had now gone to
seeing the brits as people who abandoned
his home in a tower of need as lee
himself later wrote the war had left him
determined that no one either the
japanese nor the british had the right
to push and kick us around
although lee came out of world war ii
distinctly unimpressed with singapore's
overlords that didn't mean he was
entirely done with britain after working
in the post-war black markets for a year
it pulled together enough cash to get a
boat to england to take up his studies
for four years he'd live at the heart of
the empire it was an experience that
would transform his life as lee quickly
found out britain was somehow both more
or less than he'd imagined during his
colonial childhood on the one hand he
developed a deep love for the rolling
hills of the west country and life among
the money to leak on the other hand he
soon discovered that his hosts could be
unbelievably racist so rude were so many
people to this asian man walking among
them that any remaining scales fell from
lee's eyes as he later noted i saw no
reason why they should be governing me
they're not superior still it wasn't all
bad times while in england lee finally
married quake cho more significantly for
our story though he also got deeply
involved in politics this was the era of
the atly labor government perhaps the
most left-wing in british history
helping the party campaign in
tottenham's for the 1950 election lee
began to drink in its ideas to take on
board its great plans for social housing
for establishing powerful state
monopolies when he returned to singapore
he'd carry them back with him tucked up
carefully in his heart alongside the
anti-colonial ideas that had picked up
mixing with african and indian students
although left-wing politics seemed a
natural fitfully back in singapore he
resumed his life among the money class a
young wealthy lawyer who loved golf and
fancy cars but lee was deeply aware that
left-wing politics could also mean
something more than just wealth
redistribution a chance to stick it to
the colonial administration over the
next few years lee honed his oratory
addressing strikers and defending
activists in the courts developing a
punchy street fighting style yet he took
care to keep his distance from those who
actually threw punches lee you see felt
activism had to come second to law and
order especially given the rise of
communism the 1949 creation of the
people's republic of china returned a
generation of singaporean chinese into
hardcore red activist activists
determined to win singapore's increasing
number of elected seats by now lee was
acutely aware that he'd need some of
this vast chinese population on his side
if he ever wanted to win elections but
he also detested communism his solution
the people's action party formed in 1954
pap was a shotgun marriage between
singapore's anglicized left wingers and
the chinese-speaking communists who
actually wanted to get into power from
lee's perspective though it was also a
way for him to appeal to local chinese
voters who might otherwise regard him as
unacceptably close to britain to help
sell his credentials he brushed up a
mandarin learned hockey and then just
for the heck of it he also learned tamil
by the time of 1955 election lee was
able to appeal directly to all of
singapore's major ethnic groups in their
own tongues be they chinese malay or
indian it was a stupendous feat of
learning sadly though it wasn't enough
that year pap lost out to singapore's
other major left-wing party the labor
front but what was bitterly
disappointing on that night soon turned
out to be a blessing ruling as a
minority government labor front lost
control of the striking workers causing
britain to pause singapore's timetable
for decolonization paranoid this was all
the fault of communist agitators
laborfront launched a brutal crackdown
targeting the chinese the result an
unpopular government that also did lead
the massive favor of kneecapping his
communist rivals in pap by the time of
the 1959 election the once divided party
was largely under his control the
results that made were a blowout for the
ap netting them all but eight of the 51
contested seats just a few days later on
june 3rd 1959 the british surrendered
internal control of the island at age 35
lee kuan yew became the first prime
minister of singapore yet the wunderkind
had no intention of leading his island
to complete independence instead the
b.a.p had run on a specific platform one
of taking singapore fully out of british
control and into federation with
malaysia the fulfillment of that plan
would soon become lee's greatest triumph
and his darkest nightmare alright we'll
get back to today's video in just a
minute but first a quick word from
today's video sponsor squarespace you
know what's great about the summer
vacation time off a little bit of r r
it's the perfect time to spend on the
beach daydreaming about that next
project that you want to work on
fortunately squarespace gives you every
possible tool you might want to get
started with that next project whether
it's a small business a sports blog a
creative portfolio or just a page full
of dank memes it doesn't matter if you
can dream it you can build it with
squarespace if you're looking to get in
and out quick without thinking too much
about what your website should look like
bam use one of their quick and beautiful
templates to make a website that's fresh
and for you or maybe you're more the
hands-on person you've got lots of
opinions and ideas about what exactly
your site should look like well
squarespace gives you all of the
customization options you could ever
want no updates no patches no technical
bs to worry about once you're done
setting up your website tinkering with
the design if you're so inclined or
maybe playing with the colors there are
so many extra features that squarespace
provides so your website can thrive
email campaigns patronage portals social
integrations member-only areas analytics
commercial options 24 7 customer support
really everything you need is in one
place so when you're ready to get
started go to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
your new site go to squarespace.com
forward slash biographics to save 10 of
your first purchase of a website or a
domain
and now back to it
so here's something you need to know
about singapore it really shouldn't
exist at a little over 700 square
kilometers it's a quarter of the size of
rhode island it's home to an ethnic mix
with no natural shared language or
culture plus a host of different
religions it's also resource poor
without even enough water to sustain
itself as lee himself put it long after
it somehow made this impossible state
work to understand singapore and why it
is what it is you've got to start off
with the fact that it's not supposed to
exist and cannot exist we don't have the
ingredients of a nation the elementary
factors homogeneous population common
language common culture and common
destiny hence the insane effortlessly
put into joining malaysia independent
since 1957 malaysia had the resources
and market for products that singapore
needed to stay afloat and they were
happy for their island neighbor to join
in 1961 lee met malayan prime minister
tunku abdul rahman to discuss a merger
between their nations plus sarawak and
north borneo a tentative agreement was
reached unfortunately this alone was
enough to make singapore explode while
many backed pap on malaysia a whole
bunch of chinese were terrified it could
be their ticket to becoming a persecuted
minority that summer a splinter faction
from p.a.p formed the barris and
socialist to campaign against the merger
so lee called a referendum which
returned a solid pro-malaysia majority
but when riot then broke out he decided
to put an end to the boris and socialist
once and for all launched in february
1963 operation cold store was perhaps
the first time lee kuan yew showed just
how far he was willing to go to keep
order over a hundred people including
all of baris and socialist leaders were
arrested and held without charge
effectively locked up for opposing the
merger it was a glimmering of the hard
authoritarian edge lee would display all
his life but it also ensured singapore
would join the malaysian federation on
august 31st 1963 lee held a special
ceremony to mark the end of british
influence over the island and swear
loyalty to kuala lumpur just over two
weeks later singapore ceased to exist as
an independent state and a bright new
future as part of a dynamic federation
began at least that's how the script was
supposed to go in reality lee would
barely have time to celebrate his
greatest political trial before it all
came crashing down in flames the reasons
the singapore malaysia union collapsed
to legion and vary depending on who
you're talking to but there are some
common threads from the staggering taxes
kuala lumpur levied on the island to
lee's aggressive attempt to expand pap's
reach on the mainland but perhaps the
clearest threat running through every
part of this disappointing tapestry was
the issue lee feared most of all
race to simplify a complex issue the new
malaysia wanted to promote malay culture
while lee felt only an avowedly
multicultural project could stop the
peninsula from descending into ethnic
violence when two separate race riots
paralyzed singapore knight 64 killing 36
and injuring hundreds both sides felt
their worst suspicions had been
confirmed by summer 1965 tensions were
no longer simmering so much as they were
boiling over the edges of the pot and
covering the stone in angry resentment
that june things got so bad that tunku
abdul rahman basically went you know
what to hell with this fool the process
of expelling singapore from malaysia was
as swift as it was irreversible while he
was given a few days notice to give the
illusion that this was a mutual parting
it was a clear case of jump before you
pushed on august 9 1965 lee held a press
conference to confirm what news had
reported that morning that singapore had
left the federation to call it a shock
would be an understatement most of lee's
cabinet hadn't even been told until less
than 48 hours before the announcement
but that afternoon it was lee who seemed
to be most shocked of all eyes
glistening with tears lee asked his
countrymen to stand firm to believe that
they really could survive as an
independent state later he would call
that press conference his moment of
anguish and it's easy to see why for the
first time in modern history this tiny
overcrowded island was now utterly alone
alone in a dark hostile world surrounded
by larger powers unless he wanted to be
remembered as the man who destroyed
singapore lee was going to need a
miracle
since we're living in a world where
singapore clearly didn't implode into
ethnic violence there's not much point
in us structuring this chapter like a
narrative following lee kuan yew as he
struggles to make miracles happen
instead we're going to dive into the
details of lee's rule without regard for
chronology so you can see for yourself
how he held his city-state together one
of the biggest issues the young country
faced was his ethnic cocktail one which
had already produced two notorious race
riots with so many chinese malayan
indians all crowned together singapore
was always going to be multicultural but
lee surprised everyone by how far into
that he leaned rather than favor one
language or culture over the other lee's
solution was to embrace aspects of all
of them chinese tamil and malay were all
made official languages with english
promoted as the lingua franc were to
bind them together the calendar was
stuffed with public holidays for all the
major religions with christian muslim
hindu buddhist and chinese celebrations
sprinkled throughout the year perhaps
most surprising though was housing
policy underly the housing and
development board or hdb became one of
the most powerful government department
eventually building homes for around 80
of singaporeans this is important
because many hdb blocks were given
strict ethnic quotas intended to reflect
the demographics of the country at large
in other words an enforced
multiculturalism that lee intended to
stop the formation of ghettos another
big issue was poverty if like me you
grew up long after singapore became a
byword for well-ordered and freakishly
clean it can be hard to imagine the
state it was in owen lee assumed power
the people were poor the streets dirty
tracts of land still scarred by war
damage half the population
was functionally illiterate as one
popular travel magazine of the era
sniffed utter filth and poverty one must
see with his own eyes to believe it fast
forward to 1990 and singapore would be
the second richest nation in asia so how
did this happen what potent ideology did
lee seize upon to transform this small
tropical island the answer
none grafted onto a european or american
understanding of left and right the
great singapore experiment can be
laughably hard to quantify the finance
in the free market were embraced along
with low corporate tax rates and all
sorts of incentives for international
businesses to base themselves there at
the same time though lee never forgot
the lessons he'd learned from atlee's
labor government in britain certain
sectors such as housing were dominated
by powerful state monopolies with a
level of government intrusion into
people's lives that would give most
conservatives a heart attack
most famously this came in the form of
social improvement campaigns a
hard-bitten realist lee didn't trust his
fellow humans not to be gross so he
employed a carrot and stick approach to
stop citizens from doing everything from
spitting or chewing gum to fly tipping
and failing to flush the toilet in this
case the stick was quite literal those
who acted crude in public could be
sentenced to not just fines but also
caning yet for all its weird mishmash of
what we consider right and left it's
hard to deny that these methods worked
poverty rates plummeted literacy
skyrocketed the city became cleaner
richer and more orderly than the british
could have ever dreamed back when we did
our geographic video on singapore itself
we talked and wonder about how such
ideological opposites such as margaret
thatcher and den xiaoping could both
visit and come away thinking i want to
do that yet despite his own professed
lack of ideology in a weird way you can
see a consistent logic to lee's
decisions a champion of what he called
asian values lee believed in putting the
health of society above the rights of
the individual no matter who those
individuals were that meant coming down
on corrupt government officials like a
ton of angry bricks it meant ensuring a
high-wage economy for everyone in the
public sector and creating a compulsory
saving system for health care there's a
reason millions mourned when lee kuan
yew died in 2015 and that's because he
faced a future where singapore could
have easily been poor or corrupt or just
really really divided and instead he
created a safe stable and wealthy
society but that doesn't mean it was all
a utopia it's time for us to take a
quick look at the darker side of life in
lee's gleaming metropolis one marked
less by great strides in living
standards more by creeping
authoritarianism
back in our opening oh we lumped lee
kuan yew in with some pretty unsavory
characters while that was mostly to
demonstrate how different he was from
other east asian rulers in this era it
was also because he at least vaguely
belongs in their group no one but no one
could stay in power for over 30 years
without having at least a mild
authoritarian streak and lee's streak
was sometimes a shade or two beyond mild
for starters is singapore functioned
under some pretty strict limits on free
speech and public assembly it also
featured a judiciary that was less than
independent while judges were free from
obvious interference they still towed
the pap party line on nearly all
significant rulings and speaking of pap
it wasn't just lee who became a
permanent feature of the landscape
despite technically being a multi-party
democracy with free and fair elections
singapore effectively became a one-party
state between 1966 and 1981 not a single
seat in parliament was held by a non-pap
politician when a record 40 of voters
backed opposition candidates in 2011
just six of 87 seats went to other
parties part of the reason for this was
pap's ability to spot emerging new
talents and co-opt them bringing the
best and brightest into the fold another
was the party's genuine enduring
popularity but at least part of it was
due to pap's vice-like grip over society
not just central government but local
work brigades residence committees and
local associations they all fell under
his spell to take part in civil society
almost by default had to get involved
with pap this meant a level of
identification with the party that
pretty much no one in the opposition
could muster and when they tried it
often meant trouble unlike a classic
lock em up or shoot em authoritarian lee
had a much more humane yet equally
effective way of dealing with political
opposition thanks to stringent libel
laws critics of the government could
easily be hit with devastating lawsuits
opposition star war jbj retinum was
repeatedly bankrupted by politically
motivated rulings from lee's point of
view the reason for all of this was
clear loosen things up in society just a
little and the demons of ethnic strife
or communist agitation might come
howling out again as he confessed in an
interview long after his retirement i'm
not saying that everything i did was
right but everything i did was for an
honorable purpose i had to do some nasty
things locking fellows up without trial
still sometimes this obsessive
micromanaging of society spilled over
into cartoonishness under lee's tightly
controlled rule the specific types of
trees that could be planted by roadsides
were mandated and the government even
set up its own dating agencies to try
and get high quality graduates to
reproduce more seriously an aggressive
drive to stop families having more than
two kids was so successful that it badly
damaged the birth rate leading to an
ongoing demographic crisis so yeah if
you're used to europe or america's focus
on individual freedoms life underly
probably would have seemed stifling a
democratic hero he certainly was not yet
lee never really claimed to be a
democrat he was always clear-eyed about
what he wanted to achieve via his soft
authoritarianism and the results speak
for themselves
in lee's time in power singapore's life
expectancy increased by 10 years
literacy levels skyrocketed gdp per
capita went from relatively low to among
the highest on the planet while the
nation he constructed would be one many
outsiders found oppressive william
gibson famously dubbed it disneyland
with the death penalty it was also one
in which its citizens were both
extremely safe and often extremely
comfortable but perhaps lee's cleverest
move would have come at the end of his
rule rather than simply staying in power
until he died like most authoritarians
he did something that helped prepare
this tightly controlled society for life
without him he willingly stepped down
lee kuan yew's time as prime minister
ended on november 28th 1990 when he
handed the reigns over to gorchok tong
still this wasn't the end of lee's
influence on singapore like denshopping
in china lee may have vacated the throne
but he remained a significant power
behind the scenes first as the cabinet
senior minister and then in the
specially created role of minister
mentor this way he was able to keep his
steadying hand on the tiller through all
14 years of gauze premiership right into
the early years of zelda's son lee
hassan lung's ongoing reign it was may
2011 before lee finally surrendered any
role in politics following a historic
election that saw pap's vote dropped to
its lowest level ever by then though it
was abundantly clear that the nation he
had forged would be capable of carrying
on without him lee kuan yew died on
march 23 2015 at the age of 91. as he
breathed his last it was at the center
of an island nation that had utterly
transformed in his nine decades a
one-time tropical colony that was now
both a gleaming metropolis and one of
the most avowedly multicultural nations
on earth today it's hard to overstate
the impact lee had in his long life as
pap's main visionary he more or less
created modern singapore the wealth the
safety the limits on free speech the
luxurious lives of many inhabitants they
all can be rested at his feet to be sure
the system he left behind isn't ideal
inequality remains a problem and
government censorship has gotten even
more hard hard-edged over the last
decade or so but when you look at the
cards lee was dealt after singapore
crashed out of malaysia and then look at
the results well it's hard to argue that
he didn't play his hand spectacularly
sometimes people like to talk about the
idea of a benign autocrat the leader who
may hoard power but really does have
their people's best interests at heart
normally this is just a comforting story
dictators tell themselves a handy
fiction to cover their corruption and
psychopathy yet lee was the rare ruler
who did fit this mold maybe his tactics
were at times questionable maybe he
sometimes did some bad things without
him though singapore today would likely
be a much poorer much more divided place
he may not have been perfect but lee
kuan yew was undoubtedly one very
important thing
a visionary
[Music]
you